[Music]
on to our first topic what happens to
conservatism the idea was that the
tories would charge you less from the
other guys boris johnson signed a pledge
one of his six pledges not to raise
taxes read my lips we will not be
raising taxes on income or vat or
national insurance on the contrary what
we are the lifetime of that government
for the lifetime of the of the
parliament that pledge didn't last two
years and he's saying he's raising taxes
to pay for the nhs realistically it's
for a new social care settlement to make
clear but nobody will have to sell their
house in his words to pay for their
social care
so what's happening are we seeing a big
shift to big state conservatism kate
andrews joins me now so kate let's go
through the economics here historically
this is quite a big tax rise isn't it
it is fraser according to the institute
for fiscal studies the tax burden is now
at its highest ever sustained level
let's talk it through this week the
government announced its plans to fund
its efforts to catch up on the nhs
backlog created by covet 19 and reforms
to social care it's going to do so by
raising taxes from april 2022 national
insurance is going up by 1.25 percentage
points for employees and employers so in
total it's a 2.5 percentage point hike
from 2023 it becomes its own tax a new
health and social care levy set at the
same amount the dividend tax rate is
also going up to by 1.25 percentage
points it's projected this will raise an
additional 12 billion pounds for the
treasury's coffers if you combine this
with the tax rise from the march budget
which froze the personal allowance
threshold and announced a corporation
tax hike boris johnson has achieved
record levels of peacetime spending
since these funds are mainly being
sourced through national insurance it's
people in work who will be contributing
most
so how might that affect you well if
you're earning 30 000 pounds a year
you'll be paying roughly an additional
250 pounds a year so we're talking about
hundreds of pounds transferring from the
earner to the tax man
what do you get for it well a promise
has been made to increase nhs capacity
from 110 at its current levels and to
deliver 30 more elective procedures by
2024 25 than were previously available
before the pandemic hit these clear
targets will make it easier to assess if
the government has delivered on its word
but of course there's no guarantee that
it will the nhs had a problem with
waiting lists long before the pandemic
hit as trusts often failed to reach
waiting time targets keeping people in
pain who were waiting for care
so we wait and see
as for social care the assets of the
middle class are now better protected a
lifetime cap of 86 000 pounds has been
set for what a person will contribute to
the cost of their own social care making
it far less likely that somebody might
have to sell their home to pay for care
the taxpayer instead will pick up the
bill
meanwhile more support will be given to
those who have assets between twenty
three thousand pounds and a hundred
thousand pounds they'll be eligible for
mean tested social care funding for the
first time
now there are main outstanding questions
as to how this money will be allocated
the government is instituting a legally
hypothecated levy meaning that the money
will be ring fenced by law for health
and social care but that's not
irreversible with a big enough vote in
parliament history goes to show that
hypothecated taxes and that's a specific
tax to fund a specific purpose rarely
work they tend to bloat the state but
the government likes to be able to
prioritize funds as it sees fit and
usually finds a way of working around
that
there are also questions about how much
money is actually going to social care
the deal struck is that the nhs gets the
bulk of the cash for the first few years
to address the coveted backlog can
anybody really see a scenario though
where health chiefs are happy to hand it
back or where the politics doesn't morph
into accusations of cutting the nhs
budget
the resolution foundation highlighted
this week that despite the usual
campaign cries healthcare spending is
not insignificant it currently totals 40
of core day-to-day spending and that
doesn't include emergency pandemic
spending
still it's difficult to see this money
being rolled back so already questions
are being asked about where more money
might come from
the government will have this new levy
might they up it
even with the tax burden at a near
70-year high are things only set to
worsen
tough questions for a conservative
government
back to you fraser
kate thanks very much so how is this
debate going down in the conservative
party i'm joined now by andrea litzen
who once stood for leadership of the
conservative party she's backing these
proposals now andrea thanks for coming
on bits first of all can you say a
little bit about why you're confident
but this will in any way fix social care
because as far as what we've been told
so far
it doesn't seem as if social care is
going to be reformed in any way it just
seems that a massive big check has been
written to the nhs with no real
assignment it will get anywhere near
social care
well i think millions of people are
going to be totally relieved that the
government is gripping this issue of
social care that's been docked for so
many decades but um in direct answer to
your question it is going to be a
hypothetic new tax the health and social
care levy and the the government will be
legislating to ensure that money is
going to fix the social care system
in in two areas one is to improve the
domiciliary care and the other is to
improve the care home experience so that
people don't have to lose all of their
assets to pay for their care and the
prime minister said yesterday that this
plan was progressive what did he mean
mean by progressive what way is this
progressive isn't this the poorer
subsidizing the rich
absolutely not no essentially um it's a
1.25
national insurance new national
insurance levy
for those under about nine and a half
thousand they won't pay anything for
those under 21 for apprentices under 25
for veterans from the armed forces there
won't be any national insurance
contributions for them and then for
everybody else it will be progressive so
if you're a basic great taxpayer it'll
amount to about 3 pounds 50 a week if
you're a higher rate taxpayer it'll be
about 17 pounds 50 a week and then if
you are a more wealthy individual the
top 14 percent will be paying around
about 50 of the cost of this levy right
but say for example you're a worker in a
care home on the national living wage of
about i think it's just 9 pounds eighty
an hour i saw some figures from uh
policy and practice saying with that
care home worker will be paying an extra
hundred pounds a year in tax for a fund
that could that is available to
millionaires in what way is that
progressive and what way is that
conservative
well i i i don't think that
that the real beneficiaries are going to
be as you say the millionaires versus
the poor who will be paying for it but
why not she often said that you often
put a cap on this you could very easily
upset that people who are millionaires
won't benefit from this they should pay
for their own care but rather than this
it seems to me quite explicitly you're
saying that the object of this is to
relieve people no matter how rich from
the fear of having to sell their own
home now that explicitly means that you
will be giving money to people with
bigger states a quarter of pensioners in
britain have got assets of a million
pounds or more in household assets and i
think half of the majority of pensioners
gasses of half a million pounds or more
these are households that thanks to the
asset boom are very well off
and yet the tory party is asking minimum
wage workers to come up with a fund that
can be used by them
so it is a fund that will be used by
everybody and and you're absolutely
right it is intending to cap the
contribution of every individual to
their own care but you know as well as i
do fraser that at the very top end
people are not dependent on the social
care system they are they are looking
after themselves as is the case at the
top end where this will really benefit
is those with a modest property perhaps
in the region of 200 000 pounds worth of
equity in their home that will protect
them from having to sell all of their
assets that they want to pass on to
their children or indeed risking that
they end up with nothing left in order
to pay for their own care so where it
really really benefits people is those
who are in that middle income who at the
moment if you've saved nothing if you
have nothing then you are in effect
getting exactly um the same as somebody
who's saved and done the right thing and
who is absolutely terrified about losing
all of their assets but a really
important point here also to say is that
the social care system is absolutely
broken and it has been for decades
successive governments haven't gripped
this issue and what the conservatives
are now trying to do is to once and for
all set in stone a system that actually
will transform this so that everybody
can benefit from it whether they're
elderly and with modest means whether
they are a younger person who has
disabilities or who needs um specific
care for particular issues that they
have
everybody will be able to benefit from
it so it's right that we have a broad
tax base to raise the money right but is
it what is clear is that nobody will
have to pay more than 86 000 pounds what
is clear is that you won't have to if
you've got a home that's 250 000 pounds
quarter of a million pounds you won't
have to risk that by the way that's a
lot more assets than a lot of people who
be paying this tax will have but what
isn't clear
is that this will anyway transform or
even fix social care there's money there
we haven't said how you're going to do
it really and the institute of fiscal
studies points out that there's every
chance this will be gobbled up by the
nhs the money you say is hypothecated
but it's not hypothetically towards
social care is it bother getting towards
health and social care so that's quite
possible for the nhs simply by the the
the cost inflation the last party who
did this labour party found that half of
the extra money raised by national
insurance was gobbled up by simply pay
inflation within the nhs and other forms
of inflation so there's no real
guarantee about the care home system
which claimed i think a third of the
coveted dead were passed away in care
homes a big problem there we don't
really have any idea how that's going to
be fixed
well certainly
one there's a couple points to make
there one is that health and social care
are not sort of like two separate things
the point is that people who are finding
themselves taking up hospital beds could
much better in many cases be looked
after at home that was the case during
covert it was the case before kovid lots
of families who write to their mps the
whole time saying i can't get any help
at home for my mom i don't want her to
have to go in a care home and so on so
actually you you need to sort of in a
sense
look at the two in conjunction with each
other what you spend on your social care
system will save the vast vast sums of
hospital beds but in addition to that
the government's going to be bringing
forward legislation to create a cap and
a floor system for social care so that
in effect it becomes inexorable that
money will be brought into the social
care system it won't be able to simply
be absorbed in the nhs to pay for the um
covid backlog but just to be clear you
know this is not something that's going
to go away there are five million people
now waiting for procedures and
operations as a direct result of kovid
that would rise to about 13 million by
the end of this year if we did nothing
so actually to do nothing isn't an
option so yes of course there's a lot to
be worked out in my view i would like to
see an insurance system for for social
care to top it up for people to be able
to insure their own assets and so on but
in the short term we have to do
something to deal with the covid backlog
and to sort out this social care system
that's already broken can you say a bit
more about that insurance system lots of
other countries do you have that it
seems to be an option do you think
there's potential to develop that
yeah i do actually and i was interested
yesterday the prime minister was saying
there'll be a white paper about social
care coming forward i mean i personally
having uh presided at defra over the
establishment of floodry which you might
recall was when we had those terrible
floods and people couldn't get flood
insurance so the government set up a
quasi private sector with government
backing system for flood insurance where
every household of bandy council tax or
higher had 10 pounds a year paid out of
their council tax into a pot that the
government then added to
to enable the private sector to agree to
ensure households against floods so that
kind of socializing this system but
bringing in the private sector to
actually be able to
provide some backing for it i think then
you could have a system where people
were paying insurance premiums and
potentially the older you are the richer
you are the much greater your insurance
premium would be as is the case with
private health care so i think a mixture
of um state and private sector would be
a good way to go but i think what the
government's done now is to get a grip
on something that is already broken so i
think it's absolutely essential that we
do that right what the government's done
now otherwise you say is give a lot of
money to nhs with a huge backlog but
interesting that you're saying that
insurance works for flood insurance
insurance work for floods so why
couldn't insurance work for long-term
social care as it does in other
countries isn't is it could could this
be the trick the government has missed
or do you think there's still the
potential to um to arrive at something
like this before you get into the phase
where the money is transferred from the
nhs and goes towards the care home
sector
so i think that there's two aspects to
this one is we have a system that's
broken right now so we've got this huge
backlog in the nhs and we have a social
care system where people can't get
domiciliary care the the care home the
quality of care homes and the
availability of care homes for people is
simply not there so we have a short-term
problem that we really need to fix and i
do think that biting the bullet and you
know facing up to the fact that it's
breaking a manifesto promise and so on
people will be relieved that the
government's getting a grip on it
however in the longer term i think
people who say well how do we know that
this is going to be sufficient is a very
valid question to ask so yes i would
like to see us looking at a longer term
flood re-style of
national insurance scheme that people
could buy into
andrea thanks very much indeed i'm now
joined by marcus fish who's been one of
the more outspoken rebels against what
the prime minister has announced marcus
how would you describe the reaction
amongst your fellow tories to the fairly
big announcement this week
well i intend to keep my manifesto
pledge
to not increase
these taxes
that are proposed national insurance i
think is the wrong
measure
um at the wrong time
um and i think it hits the wrong
people to be paying for something
um which we should be thinking of in a
different way and funding a different
way right you've been quite forthright
in that you describe it as a socialist
approach a big mistake it's um you don't
believe it's conservatives can you say a
bit more about that what's
unconservative about this
well what's unconservative is to
reach for tax levers at the first
instance to
to pay for costs which are temporary on
the economy in terms of the nhs recovery
from covid
and i think you know tax and spend is
what people would normally expect from
the other side of the aisle rather than
us but nobody expects a global pandemic
and you'll accept the costs of fixing
the backlog aren't what any tory could
put of a normal gamut surely these are
exceptional and policies for exceptional
times
i think we should make a distinction
between
costs
that are one-off that are not going to
recur because of the pandemic and
costs of the ongoing and recurring
need to help
our burgeoning older population with its
health and social care
needs and i think it's been a bit
disingenuous to
for the government to be mixing the two
things up
in the way that they are with this uh
very broad base and
in my view uh it will become
irreversible
tax rise now marcus in the last few days
i've spoken to quite a few tory mps who
say what you say but they're and
disturbed by this some say they're
sickened and appalled at the idea of
increasing the um the tax on somebody on
the minimum wage to subsidize somebody
with a two million pound house
the funny thing is that the tories will
complain about this but they won't vote
against it even you often voted against
it you've abstained so why is it that so
many of your colleagues i'm sure you've
had people saying to you marcus i agree
with what you're saying in public but
they themselves will not join you in
public criticism there's a sort of
fatalism about this i'm beginning to
wonder if the tory party is actually far
less opposed to this than a lot of the
backbenchers make out they are
there is very broad unhappiness about
what has been proposed and the way it's
been proposed i think people do think
it's it's unfair broadly um on the
working age population
to be taxed in this way and at risk to
their jobs
and their employers who are trying to
get back on their feet after the
pandemic i think they think it's both
politically risky and economically risky
but the reality is that we
need to give the government space to be
able to
come forward with the full proposals and
try to work with them to
get the policies changed and improved
and that's why
i think it's right
not to have voted against the government
at this stage so that we can at least
have a
constructive conversation with them
going forward and try to
fix what i think is a
uh
a misguided policy that's been done more
for sort of pr reasons
uh than for sound
policy reasons but boris johnson seems
to have
certainly got a warm reaction to this
the opinion poll suggests that voters
certainly older voters seem to think
he's made a sensible decision they
recognize that in the pandemic taxis
need to go up and a lot of people want
their care homes fixed i mean when
theresa may came up with the idea of
asking the wealthy to pay for the cost
of their own care the tory's got such a
backlash that you guys lost your
majority so i put it to you that's what
you're proposing just simply isn't
politically sellable now given what the
political power electoral power lies
where it does with older voters because
without older voters the tories would
not be in power so you guys basically
work for them from now on
i don't think that this
plan
will actually fix social care i think it
will make it worse
and i think
the people i've talked to in the care
sector and local government are
extremely worried that in fact this tax
rise money will just be taken by the nhs
and it will disappear they will never
give it up
and in the meantime
the industry has to cope with the
changes that the government has
announced
to mean for example that um
uh care providers can't cross-subsidize
their state uh funded provision with the
private uh care care residents
um and that means that many of them will
be uneconomic there'll be less capacity
in the industry in the next two years
which will make it harder to fix the nhs
with the discharge
requirements that are there to
get all the work and the backlog cleared
and i just think this is an absolute
mess of a policy um that hasn't been
properly thought through
and i think it's
basically a bit of a wheeze that someone
has thought up to use what you
mentioned which is the very good will of
the british people to
want to
to help this system which has clearly
been overloaded with lots of demand
because of the pandemic
and
forced through a tax rise um but call it
something else call it a goodwill
payment to the nhs which
people like to say that they want more
health care and they'll pay for it and
all the rest of it but face them with a
tax rise that could
interfere with the economic recovery and
let's see if they really want to pay for
that
[Music]
you